[Musique]
31 janvier 2020
le destin de l'europe bascule avec le
départ du royaume uni
deux jours plus tôt à bruxelles les
eurodéputés britanniques vivent leurs
dernières séances
[Applaudissements]
mon bonheur
pour les briques sitter c'est le jour de
gloire avec toi
et czech de santé
pour beaucoup d'autres c'est l'échec
d'une vie consacrée à l'europe
[Musique]
à l'image de ses eurodéputés
c'est un royaume uni fracturée qui a
entonné le chant du départ
[Musique]
le compte à rebours commence une semaine
plus tôt
[Musique]
puisses davis est un eurodéputé condamné
sa mort politique est programmé en même
temps que le break cible c'est un vieux
routier de bruxelles une figure du
parlement européen depuis 1999 il occupe
un poste clé président de la commission
pêche
il compte bien l'assumer jusqu'au bout
je tiens ici et je compte bien le jouer
jusqu'au bout donc le royaume uni n'aura
pas quitté l'europe je siègerai à la
tête de la commission pêche alors et je
poursuivrai mon travail puisse davis
fait partie de ces bâtisseurs discret de
l'europe
deux colloques en entretien de bureau en
salles de commissions il continue
d'arpenter sans relâche les couloirs du
parlement européen
comme si de rien n'était
mais les caméras plus nombreuses que
d'habitude sont là pour lui rappeler ce
qui l'attend dans une semaine et ça
l'agacé un peu aspen j'ai passé quinze
ans ici a essayé de communiquer sur mon
travail de montrer ce que l'europe fait
pour mes électeurs
franchement les médias ne s'y
intéressent pas même quand cela concerne
directement la vie quotidienne
aujourd'hui la seule chose qui les
intéresse c'est de voir pleurer les
eurodéputés britanniques mais les vrais
problèmes ils s'en moquent précieuse
sans écho désolé d'être cynique
qu'ils le veuillent ou non le break site
se rappelle à lui à chaque recoins du
parlement c'est ma collègue catherine
billard d'heure et fait son vide grenier
elle a écrit plutôt que ramener mes
affaires chez moi je vous invite à venir
vous servir bon je n'arrête pas de
dénicher des nouveaux trucs aux logos
est gratuit tout est gratuit
quelqu'un a déjà pris le tableau blanc 1
et la photo du tigre était dans ce cadre
est parti aussi j'ai emballé 34
éléphants ce petit là je pense que je
vais le peindre et le garder comme j'ai
beaucoup combattu les braconniers
tous les gens qui venaient me voir m'en
donner je sais pas ce que je vais faire
de tout ça chez moi j'ai déjà fait
beaucoup de cartons ceux là vont partir
aux archives européenne au luxembourg
tout ça me fait penser à un truc encore
longtemps que je fasse pareil j'ai mes
propres cartons à faire mal
c'est fou et ça me brise le coeur de
voir tout ce qu'on perd moi je suis
assez âgées je vais partir à la retraite
mais je pense aux futures générations
actuelles mais il faut maintenant qu'on
définisse notre relation avec l'europe
et éventuellement ensuite on vous
viendra parce que c'est la seule peur
des honorables
[Musique]
ce sont aussi les derniers jours pour
dire au revoir en collègue ses
partenaires d'hier et d'aujourd'hui qui
deviendront demain
presque des adversaires dans les
négociations qui se poursuivront après
le break site
salut crise telus contente de douane
sausheim et en même temps tellement
triste de savoir qu'on appose croisé
ancien secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes m ali l'oiseau est membre du
groupe de coordination du bric site
elle va participer aux négociations avec
les britanniques chris davis a bien du
mal à voir en elle le camp d'en face
alors tu pense que les négociations vont
être faciles avec le royaume uni
bien sûr allez je crois que maurice
johnson va voir son cadeau pour lui il
va pouvoir le manger
bien sûr il va même pouvoir épouser les
cuisinières aller plus sérieusement
boris c'est l'homme à l'origine de ce
référendum
je le déteste chez pas du tout envie
qu'il est son gâteau il donnera puis de
recevoir
s'il ne donne rien il aura rien n'est
pas parce que ça nous fait plaisir hulin
bien sûr qu'on veut rester partenaire
je suis vraiment dans une situation
impossible depuis pau avec je devrais
vouloir le bien de mes concitoyens
souhaité que l'europe cède le maximum à
la grande bretagne mais mon coeur me
till inverse
bon je dois l'avouer je suis encore dans
le déni
je ne peux même pas concevoir qu'on ne
pourra plus avoir cette conversation
dans mon bureau ou le tien vous allez
nous manquer terriblement
c'est comme chris davis ils sont 73
eurodéputé britannique avoir la porte se
refermer en majorité bien malgré eux ils
ont joué le jeu jusqu'à la dernière
minute plus des vice présidents de la
commission pêche pas une seconde il a
considéré que parce que y allait avoir
le bras exit ils allaient moins
travailler la liste des intéressés
c'est des européens convaincus sont pas
venus là pour avoir une place
ils sont pas venus là avec l'esprit
totalement tourné vers la politique
intérieure britannique
ils sont venus là parce que c'est des
vrais européens faut pas qu'on les
oublie
[Musique]
à vol d'oiseau 320 kilomètres seulement
séparent bruxelles de londres la
capitale britannique elle aussi semble
subir le break site 60% de ses électeurs
ont voté contre
louisa porritt est députée européenne du
même parti que cuisse davis elle est
élue de la circonscription de camden
quartier branché du nord de londres
c'est un quartier très ouvert et
cosmopolite 13 européen très
internationale en fait il y a des gens
qui viennent de paraître
c'est un endroit hyper à nous mais je
pense qu'on trouve ici tout le meilleur
de l'ombre
sourire
camden a dû se résigner aux briques site
mais l'europe est loin d'avoir disparu
des conversations jusqu'au 31 décembre
londres et bruxelles doivent encore
négocier leurs relations futures
bonjour je suis mise à pleurer et
enchanté loi et bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne c'est bien ça oui
encore pour une semaine en tout cas oui
c'est vrai et oui puisque nous avons
perdu la bataille
ça me désole vraiment pour moi c'est un
pas en arrière sincèrement maintenant je
n'ai aucune idée de ce qui va se passer
vous pensez qu'on pourra trouver un
accord d'ici à la fin de l'année dans ce
pays si non je ne pense pas et j'espère
que boris johnson va demander à
rallonger la période de transition
après on aura de toute façon un résidu
avec ou sans accord et vous qu'est ce
qui va vous arriver à la fin du mois et
vous perdez votre emploi travail se
termine c'est assez dur pour moi
du coup c'est terminé n'y a plus aucun
moyen de s'opposer au brésil
on doit juste laissé tomber non je pense
que les voies européennes vont continuer
à se faire entendre d'une façon ou d'une
autre on a évidemment perdu la bataille
pour rester mais je pense qu'un jour ou
l'autre on reviendra alors au titre en
double et raisonnablement je dirais dans
dix ans
en attendant cette hypothétique retour
les europhiles de londres doivent déjà
encaissé le break site au peuple c'est
soirée forever european européen pour
toujours
ces londoniens ont milité en vain pour
un second référendum
ce soir il console tatiana cette
italienne vit très mal le vrai xi
tatiana depuis combien de temps du tout
en angleterre pour un quart de siècle
et maintenant tu dois demander un statut
de résident ouais bon vivre dans sa
propre maison
oui c'est humiliant c'est vraiment
mignon je paie mes impôts ici j'utilise
presque jamais la sécurité sociale donc
mes cotisations elles servent à soigner
tous et brésis teurs filière me sens
plus aimé des gens au travail qui ne
comprennent rien et qui me disent oh
mais tu vas pas être expulsés que
l'appui très longtemps pourquoi est
inquiété je suis furieuse
le bric site aura d'énormes conséquences
ça va changer la vie de l'une et lyon
deux personnes
les plaies du bric sites vont mettre du
temps à cicatriser
le référendum de 2016 a durablement
divisé les britanniques jusque dans les
familles
mamie bonne forme j'ai de la famille est
très proche qui n'a pas voté comme moi
et je peux vous dire que ça a été une
expérience horrible manqué ce sont mes
enfants des adolescents qui nous ont dit
d'arrêter ils ont dit vous ne pouvez pas
vous engueuler à cause de ça c'est fait
maintenant il faut aller de l'avant
on aimerait s'excuser auprès de nos amis
européens la grande-bretagne a été
tellement 1 grâce est stupide de partir
guillaume le brec site nous a énormément
divisé énormément de vent est ce qu'on
peut comparer ça à donald trump aux
états unis
trois ans après le vote une forme
d'incrédulité persiste londres comme
l'europe n'a pas vu venir le break sites
comme si ces lumières avait caché une
autre angleterre lucie harris c'est une
députée de 29 ans élu du nord-est de
l'angleterre elle connaît bien la
capitale elle ya étudié dans une
prestigieuse université
il faut bien comprendre qu'il fait à
londres on est dans une bulle
c'est une ville pour les jeunes
dynamiques qui veulent grimper les
échelons en cours les profs nous ont
toujours martelé que l'europe était une
bonne chose il n'y avait jamais d'avis
contradictoires
c'était l'union européenne est
formidable point final
il ya des personnes pour dire et
attendez une minute lucie harris a
choisi l'autre camp celui du break site
pendant des mois elle a organisé des
réunions et des soirées dans toute
l'angleterre ce soir d' il ne s'agit
plus de convaincre mais de fêter
l'événement ou et l'eurodéputé chauffe
la salle
c'est
correspond aux listes a révélé galles
la victoire des briques sitter se
savoure encore en sous sol loin des
regards
a londres ils font plutôt profil bas
depuis trois ans et cela pourrait bien
changer
je n'oserai jamais porter ça dans la rue
je l'enlève quand je prends le métro
j'ai trop peur de me faire tabasser
je pense que ça va commencer à changer
maintenant ça a été dur on a tous été
insulté je l'étais le lendemain du
référendum
le type m'a dit tu est plein de haine
j'ai honte de toi et de mon pays
40% des londoniens ont quand même voté
pour le brésil c'est comme si on était
une espèce dangereuse qui ne devrait
surtout pas proliférer
moi des collègues ont vu que j'avais
posté quelque chose sur facebook y en a
un qui m'a dit que je le faisais
vraiment chier en ce moment les six
derniers mois ont vraiment été pénible
est-ce qu'on peut juste arrêter de
parler de ça et enfin passer à la suite
oui maintenant il faut qu'on parle
business il faut qu'on voit les
nouvelles opportunités sur le marché
mais tous les profiteurs ne se cache pas
pour s'en rendre compte il faut
rejoindre l'épicentre du brds excité
rouler jusqu'à la mer - de long les
villes côtières britanniques ont
massivement voté pour la sortie de
l'union européenne 64% à l'oyster tu
sais la ville la plus à l'est du royaume
uni
une angleterre grise figé
des zones industrielles en friche et un
port de pêche qui pleure sa splendeur
passée
quand j'avais 15 ans tous les quais que
vous voyez là était complètement rempli
de bateaux de pêche et chalutiers
c'était toute une aventure de venir ici
il se passait toujours quelque chose et
tout le monde se parle et il y a trente
ans en 85 bateaux stationnés ici ils ne
sont plus qu'une douzaine pour stephen
l'europe est directement responsables de
ce déclin
tous les pêcheurs ont voté pour leur
exil
je n'en connais pas un seul qui ai voté
contre si j'avais voté pour m j'imagine
que je ne serai pas un vrai pêcheur on
veut juste récupérer nos eaux
territoriales
on veut des quotas moins contraignant
pour pêcher plus de poissons et avoir de
meilleurs prix les pêcheurs britanniques
se sont sentis dépossédés de leur faute
les plus poissonneuses d'europe
plus de quotas plus de pêcheurs
étrangers c'est la promesse du brds
excite et celle de john munch cette
députée européenne élue en mai dernier
aux côtés de nigel farage est la
propriétaire du marché aux poissons de
lowestoft sur le port elle vend le bric
sites comme le remède miracle on va
sortir de là et reprendre le contrôle
total de nos grâce à ça on va
ressusciter toutes les villes côtières
du pays oui on va en finir avec les
quotas oui puisqu'on va reprendre le
contrôle
il y aura plus de bateaux écoute j'ai
une stratégie et je vais bientôt
l'arrivée ce sera absolument merveilleux
pour les villes comme love story thiam
hausse malgré ce but savalli beaucoup
beaucoup mieux et je le sens on a
travaillé nature et maintenant voix à
nous de jouer
anas letecheur il va en mer il sèche il
ramait le poisson afin d'employer
quelqu'un ensuite le vent ça fait deux
emplois passent même le poisson par à
l'usiné de transformation et ça fait 3
après le restaurateur et à la fin le
consommateur le mans je fais chier mais
c'est pas que l'histoire d'un poisson on
habite bateau mais on doit encore élever
ses médecins ne pas souhaiter ça fait
des ingénieurs des idées à trie siens
après iem toute l'administration et les
bureaux qui vont avec l'industrie crée
alors des milliers et des milliers
d'emplois en europe
awilo stock sera absolument merveilleuse
[Musique]
difficile dans ces rues terne d'imaginer
un tel miracle économique
mais jude meury y croit
le prêt xi peu métamorphoser la hausse
toft
le supermarché du centre a fermé
comment les commerces autour peuvent-ils
s'en sortir ce magasin il était là
depuis des années faire mieux ici aussi
on avait un grand centre commercial
fermé le centre ville se bat pour
survivre
la principale raison anciennement
d'argent et c'est en cela que le break
site est extrêmement important il va
ramener une industrie qui nous a été
volé l'industrie de la pêche spécial
l'impatience de john murphy va prendre
fin attendue redouter le bric site c'est
pour aujourd'hui
mercredi 29 janvier 2020 le grand
hémicycle de bruxelles est prêt pour le
vote des 7 151 députés européens
aucun suspense
hormis les britanniques même les députés
les plus hostiles aux briques sites vont
respecter l'accord et votez pour la
sortie du royaume-uni à les tâches des
briques sitter c'est le d-day
c'est pour ce jour-là que jumbo lui et
son collègue ont été lus à bruxelles six
mois plus tôt dont jean martin salut
comment ça va hein ça va bien et toi oh
c'est le grand jour aujourd'hui un oui
le grand jour le jour on sort enfin de
l'europe
ces deux derniers compte à rebours je
suis tellement impatients à moi aussi
on a le vote cet après midi ces
eurodéputés sont venus à bruxelles pour
en repartir le plus vite possible leurs
bureaux sont vides et l'ont toujours été
toutes mes affaires les voilà j'ai ça ça
pour ça mon ordinateur quelques
paperasse et c'est tout je n'ai jamais
fait de cet endroit ma mère parce que je
n'ai jamais voulu qu'il soit ma maison
oui donnez nous n'avons même pas besoin
de leurs cartons ils m'ont donné 13
mais je crois que dans toutes mes
affaires d'eurodéputés vont tenir dans
un bagage cabine et ses taux
à l'autre bout du parlement chris davis
lui a du mal à décrocher
encore un dernier colloque sur la pêche
un dernier échange sur la protection des
océans
et voici l'heure des adieux
je ne veux pas rendre ce moment triste
je veux que vous pensiez tous aux
grandes initiatives de crise qui
resteront dans ce parlement
il gardera vos contacts à tous
et s'il voit que son héritage n'est pas
respectée il nous enverra des mails si
ce nom vous passera des coups de fil
chaque jour chaque jour je le ferai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant c'est terminé non
oui pratiquement pratiquement alors
pourquoi vous continuez que ce matin
mais parce que c'est ma passion
pourquoi ce que je le ferai pas qu'est
ce que je pourrais faire aller boire
dans un bar et me mettre à pleurer et
derrière la tristesse de la colère
contre son pays
mais le peuple à voter pour leurs écrits
sur la news ok mais je pense que c'est
une trahison
c'est une trahison aux intérêts de mon
pays mon pays sera plus faible
comment peut-on résoudre le changement
climatique comment peut-on améliorer la
qualité de l'air comment peut-on
améliorer notre sécurité et combattre
les organisations terroristes si nous ne
travaillons pas avec nos partenaires
européens
c'est no fun du parti conservateur veut
le faire croire que nous les
britanniques nous sommes si fort si
fantastique que nous n'avons pas besoin
de travailler avec ces étrangers de
l'autre côté de la manche
c'est mon dieu ça me rend malade
mais malade non c'est n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi c'est juste stupide
stupide l'eurodéputé n'ira pas au pot de
départ organisé par le parlement
la veille tout de même il a partagé
quelques verres avec ses collaborateurs
c'était très émouvant et j'ai beaucoup
mieux j'ai tellement bonne que je suis
revenu à mon bureau ici pas travailler
c'était juste après minuit le parlement
était complètement vide et g
je me suis assis sur une chaise et j'ai
pleuré assez fort tout seul dans ce
grand bâtiment
mon assistant ici dit tout le temps que
je m'intéresse de trop près à la
tragédie grecque
je vais y aller
la sonnerie annonce le dernier acte
juste davis par pour l'hémicycle comme
on part à l'abattoir
la dernière séance va durer quatre
heures
avec les l'arbre
un tour du monde je sais dans mon coeur
je reviendrai un jour dans cette chambre
c'est pour célébrer la de retour dans la
maison de l'europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et les rires nigel farage défilent
institutions jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous moquer du populisme
mais je vais vous dire un truc marrant
c'est devenu très populaire et
s'appelant davantage lutte contribution
financière plus courants européenne de
justice
plus tu politique commune de pêche mais
plus de contraintes m'a plu de
harcèlement je sais que nous allons vous
manqué je sais que vous allez venir
notre drapeau national ou mais nous
allons vous dire au revoir et nous
espérons à l'avenir j'ai travaillé avec
vous pouvez vous s'il vous plaît ranger
ses drapeaux
le vote est une formalité
621 pour l'accord de retrait 49 contre
des eurodéputés antibes rexie de tous
les pays entend alors le chant du départ
un chant d'espoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que toi c'est une émotion heureuse je
sens que mes coeur est plein de joie
parce que nous partons
[Musique]
c'est un cadeau que nous a offert une
union européenne et qu'est ce qui est
écrit est écrit merci pour votre
contribution je ne suis pas sûr que ça
s'adresse à nous je pense qu'ils donnent
ça tout ce qui passe l'enfant de bon
coeur on se quitte bons amis de débats
voilà exactement
pour lui si harris la victoire a un goût
de revanche
ça
je suis tellement heureux de quitter cet
endroit je vais tenter de me faire
insulter pour rien j'en avais marre que
les gens me traitent de phase iib cette
idiote
alors que je ne réclamerais que la
liberté pour notre pays pourquoi vous ne
détestez vous autant cet endroit du site
je les déteste parce qu'il représente
tout ce qui est nôtre les peuples cenis
passer par le feu c'est un endroit où
les gens ordinaires ont été oubliés
[Musique]
à votre santé a pris disait dans
l'hôpital jeetoo pas y aller
[Musique]
ces brigades n'allez pas penser que ça
vient d'ailleurs
[Musique]
je ne me poserai pas y aller
nous vous aimons vraiment en angleterre
d'accord n'oubliez pas ça
adieu ou au revoir
les eurodéputés du royaume uni qui
quitte le parlement de bruxelles en même
temps que ce sont 65 millions de
britanniques qui ce soir-là tourner le
dos à l'europe
son
[Musique]
moi
ok
[Musique]
ça